Great.
Now that you have the context for
what makes up a LinkedIn profile,
it's time to start building.
The first step of building is
establishing a strategic mindset.
You should keep these
three goals in mind.
Goal number one, show up in
search with the right keywords.
Keywords matter because it is one of the
primary ways recruiters find LinkedIn
profiles.
Goal number two, Once your profile
is found, make sure it stands out.
There are a lot of profiles in LinkedIn,
so
you want yours to not only be
searchable, but also be memorable.
Goal number three, signal that you
are qualified and motivated for
your desired job.
You want to make a good
first impression.
Next, try to personalize
these big picture goals so
you can understand what to be
included in your LinkedIn profile.
To help you with this, conduct
an exercise I like to call the three Rs.
The three Rs are Reflect,
Research, and Relate.
Now, it's your turn to
get the three Rs a try.